no
matter how bad my mental health gets
like it'll always be better than
somebody that drives a
truck like a Ford
F-150 I just feel like those are the
least introspective people on the
planet cuz every time they get out of
the truck every time they get out of the
truck they tuck the mirror in it's like
why not instead of tucking in why don't
you take a good long hard look in
it and reflect you
know maybe you're the reason your family
doesn't talk to
you you know it's not gas pric of the
government like it's just who you are
it's a human being because people that
drive trucks they're always like they're
always so mad about the gas you know but
it's like well you drive the largest
recreational vehicle
available if you just knew who you were
and drove a Chevy Vault you wouldn't
have that
problem you know people would still come
home for
Thanksgiving